this is my talk it's about deep learning
for kusa mysterious for abbreviation so
I just start off by talking about me
very very so yeah my name is rich I'm a
third year PhD student studying in
chemistry in which University pictures
has anyone been to Cambridge before yeah
so yeah if you haven't come and visit us
we've got beautiful chapels we've got
lovely lovely bridges built by genius
mathematicians apparently fantastic
colleges this business isn't st.
Catharines which is actually the best
college yeah just so happens to be mine
and absolutely beautiful chemistry
departments really the jewel of the city
so in this chemistry department this is
my group my P is dr. Andres bender his
face we've got 20 PhD students five
postdocs and welcome cheminformatics and
bioinformatics problems so this is
basically chemistry in biology in a
computer we've got all of these
different topics if you're interested
come and talk to me or even send an
email to my supervisor here some
pictures and yeah we collaborate widely
with industry and academia and we're
growing quickly so definitely come and
talk to us so why am I here at PI data
well I learned to program only three
years ago so that's basically other
started my PhD and I used three
languages JavaScript and my third yeah
and I love fighting it's definitely the
best
so my talk deep learning for Keisha I
was toying with putting putting as two
words in here I thought it might engage
lots of people people's interests but do
I even want lots of people's interest
they're not sure so yeah that's deep
learning it's really just unreasonably
good I could just leave it like that
but it's good for image recognition
speech recognition natural language
processing and many many more things
it's really cool so many good
applications everyone's got their
favorite mine is this automatic
captioning thing so what it does is it
takes a little it takes an image and not
only can it recognize people in the
image or objects it can actually tell
you what is in the object in the image
as just a normal English sentence is
incredible
and not only that you can just ask what
what was that word what made you think
that and it'll tell you that so really
if you can do do something as complex as
that I thought I'm gonna I'm gonna use
these I'm gonna use these for my work
this this will help so yeah it was all
the board the deep learning hype train
for me so now you saw this this is
probably and I'm not sure if you've read
the the information or not lots of
people might leave here what this is I
thought might thought it was some sort
of spaceship so this is quantitative
structure-activity relationship and this
is sort of a summary of what it means
the basic assumption is that all
molecule be based on can't read the
basic assumption for all molecule based
hypotheses is that similar molecules
have similar activities so that's that's
raishin ship Thanks
so what is the cumene quantitative
that's just it's a regression what's the
structure it's one of these seeing some
people yeah chemistry it's not always
that popular this is very time soon so
bear with me
this is caffeine if if anyone didn't
notice what I've got here so if you
haven't seen any of these before
these are atoms the beads of nodes in
this this graph and bonds the edges and
we obviously being chemists we need to
be sitting and leave out all the carbons
that's just what that means so a a is
for activity and it's a very broad term
we use it everywhere informatics
bioinformatics it could mean anything
really it's just very very unhelpful it
could be a protein affinity protein an
addition or activation cell doxa city
phenotypic responses even physical
properties although sometimes we take us
PR rather than QSAR so a tends to be
biological we're going to be looking at
protein affinities in this this little
talk so this is sort of like an idea of
what we're trying to model fortunately
we're not going to be doing lots and
lots of physics but you see this is this
is basically the caffeine coming in
floating and just sticking in to a a to
a adenosine receptor that's that's
basically how you stay a week and people
say don't do live demos but I just
so how do you measure these you use one
of these and if these sorts of plots
here you change the concentration and
measure the activity
it's very laborious which is why you use
one of those research students so
finally I was for a relationship and
it's just basically talking about
mapping map molecules to a number and
hopefully also included why we love
random forests and future importances as
always why so there's quite a lot to
compete against so what is it good for
absolutely nothing
probably not the basic idea is drugs for
Big Pharma just you know needs every
help it can get because testing drugs is
very very expensive and it would be good
to virtually screen out compounds that
are unlikely to be good drugs rather
than spending all the money testing them
but also be good to know how any drugs
that already exist actually work that's
what we call the mode of action so those
are the two sort of reasons why we might
want to model those those sorts of
things especially compounds modulating
proteins because even higher level
things such as toxicity is dependent on
the action of drugs on proteins so
there's there's lots of reasons for
doing it but why should we use deep
learning to build Kusama models so when
I was looking at deep learning
I was looking at all the image
processing and and it's really
fascinated me how basically neuro
networks learn features they're just
learn feature detectors that's it and
then even more interesting how the
features become sort of low-level such
as these edges and all the way up to
sort of yeah parts of faces and then
whole faces and it's not just for facial
recognition it's any sort of image you
always end up with these things it's
really interesting you just learn weird
image has anyone seen this image
it's I'm seeing a couple of nods so
Google trained a big neural network on
YouTube and this was one of the high
level nodes that they actually manage to
see it's a cat detector didn't they this
was all unsupervised and managed to
recognize a cat and YouTube but yeah
it's really really interesting good
paper so if I take an image I can
extract the different levels of features
there we go from raw pixels just of
maybe edges or lots of diffuse
properties and then extract facial
features and then finally faces what I
and increasing complexity and higher
level so I use these these are these are
these are my life depressingly but what
what I thought and how I look at
molecules is small sort of atoms it go
and make up what we call functional
groups so atoms make up functional
groups which make up what we might call
pharmaco fors and it's the same Formica
fills are sort of complex features and
functional groups intermediate features
and athens are so like the raw pixels of
the molecules so i thought running my I
might not have just jumped on it because
it's a so massive popularity trending
thing maybe it might actually be helpful
you can tell this is a paper not by me
personally lots of other people thought
too even in Google and people
getting into the school not very well
known for their sort of pharmaceutical
program but I guess anything deep
learning equals got to do and the other
reason was multitask learning so if
you've ever trained on a mist like this
you probably use a new network a little
bit like this you'll see there's 10
output neurons each of these are
basically a separate task where it's the
softmax pass that they sort of joined
together a bit but one detects whether
or not a certain number is present in an
image and yes they shared the weights
for all these layers and all these
different tasks just by themselves might
be impossible for them but if you pull
them all together you sort of leverage
statistical power of huge amounts of
data and you might actually be able to
make some progress on a on a hard
problem so we have things like this for
this in fact we've got thousands and
thousands of proteins that we might want
to model so maybe maybe that's not such
a bad idea there after all so this is
what I did this I did some deep learning
started abouts of started so of the year
and yes starlets started off trying to
gather data and it sucks it's really
really really messy so one of the big
problems is always sparse and compounds
are never really tested on all the
different outputs you'll see in my data
is less than 1% actually filled in so
it's really bad it's also really really
noisy and errors actually up to a order
of magnitude coming out of these these
sort of screens that they do so really
difficult to predict for stuff and
sometimes it's just wrong it's it's
actually these things would pan assay
interference
compounds which just sew tinker with how
an assay works and giving false readings
so for example if your assay is if your
assay is monitoring a drug giving out
just doing what monitoring a protein
doing a process and you've labeled it so
that it it glows if it's working so yes
fluorescent what happens if you put a
drug in there but it's the dosa
fluorescent it's so yeah finally and
this is also a terrible terrible issue
so the data is often very unevenly
distributed so the pharmaceutical
companies have very limited money a lot
of it but this sort of thing so
expensive that when they find something
that works that'll stick with it you'll
see you'll see serve hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of compounds or
almost exactly the same they all have
changed one atom and these come this
makes the the whole of chemical space
really really really sort of uneven huge
huge pockets and then just empty chasm
so it's really difficult to actually
train models that reflects chemical
space rather than sort of things that
some big drug companies decided to do
and so finally it's also inconsistent
data is usually from different assays
for different labs it's all measured in
different techniques so you might think
I said lost cause well there's this
thing called Campbell from the EBI I
like to think of it as the light and the
darkness it collects all the open access
data cleans the data and
links the the data to sort of standard
identifier so you might have had quite a
few screens coming out of Novartis
targeting the same same proteins as
screens that have come out of an echo
they don't want to play play nice
together
knowing they won't tell you that the
second target chemical goes and finds
and just binds them all together so you
actually know what it's like and you can
imagine it's complicated so they've got
a nice nice relational database here's
the schema it's quite quite something
that when you start your PhD here first
day yeah just get some data out of that
so I can tell you that's where all the
chemical structures are that's where all
the targets are so we have to do SQL
madness and we've we've got lots of
different attempts at doing this
filtering out things that shouldn't be
joined together I'm sure I'm sure I end
up want to do it's great so I run all of
these scripts written together basically
just compounds two targets I just want
big hundreds 250,000 length effective
array of compounds links to as many
activities on as many proteins which are
going to be the target variables so
there's 500,000 activities you get about
two two compounds two activities per
compound and about 710 proteins which is
tiny tiny just very very sparse this is
dopamine d2 receptor which is example
you can see this sort of distributed
around about here and this is in units
of
raishin this is normally distributed so
pocket of something looks very inactive
yeah it's too hard to clean all of this
up so anyway you need to you need to
calculate features and there's clever
clever ways of using people learning to
do this now but when I started I didn't
do it and this is basically talking
about the project that I did then so we
use these things full circular
fingerprints and this is a compound
caffeine again what we do for every atom
we take the environment at different
radiuses so this is at radius zero and
you see we only have one carbon atom in
here
so we take carbon atom we use a hash
function on this list and it just turns
it into a number take it to sort of just
using water 2048 and it was just five so
we just set five as is like the index in
our feature array right here more
different atoms in here hash that again
and it goes to three or whatever and you
keep on doing that and eventually you'll
end up with a future vector just means
so similar compounds will have similar
feature vectors because of this it's a
bit more complicated than that because
you need to decide different nitrogens
and different environments are going to
be completely different but it's the
same for other things I won't go through
that because this is in the chemistry
conference is it so you repeat that for
all the atoms and you light up with it's
just a big matrix really so finally
going up to modelling yeah so I decided
to use Karis with DNA I've looked at
tensor flu but I found back in January
that it was in fact tensor slow so yeah
I'm really really excited to try now but
it was pretty so I did I did try it out
and it was about four times lower so I
start with the uneo for now and then
first of all start
vacation model no I said Q Q and Mike
you saw this is normally how we do this
sort of thing we basically separate
what's the cool hits these are things
with non-negligible activity from misses
which are just things that don't really
touch the bridging the protein and it's
a way of correcting for the terrible
terrible terrible accuracy so you
normally just binarize around a certain
axis and then that gives you ones and
zeros for all of your different
activities and I've already calculated
all this circular fingerprints so this
is just a network it's great that you
can just sort of put a bit of pipe in it
and it's actually really readable so
long as you know a little bit about deep
learning yeah it's been quite a long
time coming up with this mind you this
piece is ours and has little previously
I was talking about watching the
progress tick on by spent hours and
hours of watching watching bars go up
but this this was the best sort of thing
that I managed to find out let's just
use batch normalization use batch
normalization it's so good makes your
models train really quickly and I found
this normal initializations really good
as well it's all about keeping keeping
your accuracy in is that question sorry
back with batch normalization so it's
it's a process for you you basically
normalize your activations so that's the
office of from each know each layer so
that it's 0 mean unit variance I think
it's a bit more complicated than that
but it just it it means you control for
the exploding or vanishing gradient
problems oh yeah and the final thing is
really is those
so Sigma lady things those things tend
to work very well and so yeah I
basically trained it using binary
cross-entropy furs it's a classification
model and yeah I noticed I'm not not
using sort of a soft max here so you can
use entropy and yeah also the atom
optimizer this this is very country
style thing so I trained it just using
like this
deep learning becomes so cat that it's
great this is what happens basically you
just leave this the thing going for
everything cook an egg on there so yeah
my computer actually ended up blowing
blowing up after I had trained it for an
excessively long time there's a five
year old computer but it was a very
expensive graphics card luckily I think
the graphics card is okay but we've been
trying to get a replacement for that for
ages I've been actually doing it on my
home computer from now on just load a
little bit never mind
so this is a lot of learning curves that
you get out so you can see ya the loss
keeps on going down and it's perfect
perfect machine learning problem like
you can see good fit and then start
overfitting in the loss keep from going
down but the ballasts going up so you
want to stop about 60 bucks in for
optimal things and just plotted some
metrics here and these are all the
numbers that come out they're pretty low
but realistically when you're binarize
incarcerated normally it's the decision
boundary is where most of your data is
it's a terrible terrible idea to do
normally that yeah sure if you're you
have to do something and yeah these are
pretty good numbers
so I actually compare it to logistic
regression which is what we used to use
put in put in the features and logistic
regression is basically just the same as
using one a one yeah I'm not sure how
how much better looks pretty pretty huge
actually
but those graphs didn't really work so
caffeine my trusty companion was in the
test set fortunately I needed a compound
to try things out on and so yeah the
model had never seen before so try to
predict for it you get something that
looks like this and yeah basically the
model predicted what I'm feeling
my adenosine receptors have been
activated and then were weak so yeah
it's actually I was really surprised
what predicted adenosine receptors my
name in aqsa days is so yeah this is by
the coincidentally this target that we
showed before and then I found this
paper I had no idea that caffeine tended
to work on one of the bases but it does
so yeah predicted a thing that I didn't
necessarily know about yes so that's all
well and good but I said we needed a Y
as well as a what so we want to try and
work out some sort of features basically
in an image net and this is this is my
girlfriend's hat by the way I just
needed to share what you can do is you
can slide this black box around and
monitor how your outfit change is and if
the output changes a lot and you know
whatever was under the fact box is
important I've definitely seen people do
this in image recognition
and so you basically calculate your
features out here and maybe your output
was not point 8009 that was from the
previous one now this is actually really
difficult and my cheminformatics package
bodykit which is another fantastic thing
if you're ever going to use any insists
on open source like fantastic this is
all implemented already
it's called similarity maps and then
difference like this was relevant so
this is what happened with the dancing
and everything was relevant which I was
a bit disappointed I what kind of wanted
to see maybe one half of the molecule
binding but if you look it sort of
rolled around in here so so maybe all
the molecule is relevant it's quite a
small molecule so there's definitely
curd just all bind I think it's likely
that there's a structural analog of a
training set Italy which is kind of
cheating but this was for monoamine
oxidase and I couldn't find any crystal
structures that these sort of mounted in
the proteins just go and see if so
compound two because I sort of plugs
into the protein like that but maybe it
does maybe that's the way it binds so
maybe the black box isn't such a black
box after all so finally I going to
regression models normally when you go
from sort of a classification one to
actually predicting real values you've
got to change everything about your
model I changed one thing which is to
change the activation to linear new
networks a great like that oh yeah and
change the loss as well but pretty much
the same same architecture
and using some absolutely over here
which is just something out the
difference between what you predict and
the actual true value I looked at square
error as well this one tended to work a
little bit better there's any one
problem can anyone can anyone see what
the problem is
obviously not no Nan's
because my data was really sparse and I
can't just binarize it and go if I
didn't know about didn't know what the
value was I'll just assume it's inactive
I need to know what all of the labels
were to just put it into my model here
you'll notice that I didn't didn't I
just previously use the string for the
lost function had to specify a function
here and this is what I have to do so if
anyone needs to train on sparse
multitask data this is a difficult at
least using carrots so yep you just
basically say the costs because if you
find the cost that owed man and just say
I don't care about also the contribution
there and then you get a normal number
out when you sum them all up and you're
finally able to Train honestly I've
spent weeks maybe months trying to get
it to actually train on these sorts of
data and this was the first that I got
out and actually didn't manage to
improve on it much as I was using the
architecture that was good for
classification and Oh apart from one
thing this had some l1 normalization I
think the model that was producing these
other features had those two as I kind
of wanted to have sparser features l1
normalization to do that so you don't
have just a mishmash with every single
possible chemical environment
contributing in some way to your hidden
representations but yeah you end up with
something like that this how you fit it
these are the plots for all 500 or
there's 500 thousand points somewhere
somewhere in all of those you noticed
the training sets a lot more fitted so I
definitely over fitted but yeah this
this was before I used the l1
regularization actually it gets a do
that so now to compare to other
techniques you yeah really just end up
like performing enforce quite a lot this
is just leveraging loads more data sets
I only did it for dopamine d2 receptor
because around average take forever to
Train at least on this poor little
laptop that had to train train neural
networks rages on on its tiny little GPU
so I didn't didn't stress it out too
much but it worked out and I did end up
doing it for quite a few other compound
other proteins so finally I was just
looking at some transfer learning you do
this but basically slicing the last
classification there off and you just
learning using the hidden representation
so the penultimate layer that sort of
the idea is those that are you're like
learned Formica fours and that should
give you a better so feature set to
differentiate so I trained it on only 20
compound 20 tartar and proteins sorry
and yeah this what happened to Morgan
fingerprints of the circular
fingerprints that I was using you see
like it's not that much of an
improvement but it's pretty good pretty
video pretty great so anyways that was
just a little going through some deep
learning not on image recognitions so I
just like to thank my supervisor and
for some good discussion good against
the guy who who did the deep talks talk
depose paper sorry my group and the
potato sponsors and also my funding body
the engineering of Physical Sciences
Research Council College University and
then video for giving me the GPU that I
haven't plugged into any computer for
ages because right questions do you
think much of interesting in your in
your new network you have layers that
roughly correspond to the search of
infant the functional group the for yes
always there something that you can do
to make one layer particularly target
something sorry
oh is that just a coincidence all
designed in there
the targets that's what we optimize
against so we changed the weights
specifically to try and get the output
layers to be as close as possible to all
the known data so the known data or the
target affinity data and we hope that
the intermediate layers sort of form the
same sort of hierarchical feature
structure that we see in lots of other
different network architectures I
haven't if you went to say 16 layers is
that going to help model it was actually
again the way I suspect I wouldn't be
able to train it because you get some
errors going all over the shop and
probably wouldn't fit in with GPUs and
stuff like that but maybe I there if
you've looked at the res nets which just
recently one image net those are really
really really deep but the problem with
is you just you just lost your gradients
or they exploded you
you can train it but there's special
tricks and can train these really really
really deep ones I'd like to try that I
assumed that I would not be able to I
actually haven't tried hi I mean when
you introduce your features you said
that those are ones you started using
but like later some really clever ones
came out
did you actually introduce those later
on or no no sorry I've been using those
but it's I didn't think I'd be able to
fit them into the talk and published
them and yes some others have been
published
I'd rather yeah maybe they may be next
nice presentation come and talk to me
afterwards if you want to know about
them I'm happy to talk about them but I
didn't want a big presentation
one technique that have heard about a
lot to East last few days and not much
in the literature about deep learning is
trying to see what other cases that feel
and add them to the model because I seem
to have access to cheap university
students to do the experiments and the
big machine house have you tried that is
it possible with your very sparse data
set so no it would be really interesting
so we I sadly do not have access to
hundreds of robots so one of our
collaborators causes PhD students I
don't have access to to a whole team to
do experiments we've got a couple of
people who do them but realistically
that's for the farmer to do this is
where most of our data comes I think
about half of it comes from scientific
literature so these are the experimental
labs and half of it comes from the big
pharma dumping data that they don't
think is bad before so yeah I think
people yeah if you had the resources to
do it be really interesting and knowing
which ones to test it sort of almost
active learning style other things which
is actually already been explored by a
couple of pharmaceutical companies
already there's definitely a big active
learning project going on so sort of but
I haven't got the resources to try
anything like that
hi the way the way that you sort of
hashed the chemical structures is that
standard and are you losing any
information
it's very standard in its
state-of-the-art way of representing so
the structural properties of the
compound so you if you get the same
compound they have the same features or
the same feature vectors and similar
compounds tend to be similar and you can
do sort of Jaccard similarity is and
stuff like that to compare them however
they ignore huge amounts of information
for instance shape and and everything
apart from the chemical graph and the
anthem types so yeah right yeah so I was
thinking like we normally represent them
in two dimensions and deep learning
you started with image recognition I was
thinking you might have something in two
dimensions to represent the structure
and then I think go with that but yeah
so I guess you don't really want to
represent a compound in two dimensions
because they're there in three
dimensions and there's actually been
some really interesting work on that
actually as well I'm not sure if they
use it on compounds but they use it on
proteins where you did a 3d
convolutional neural network based sort
of model binding sites on a protein
using a 3d computational neural network
but yet the the the way that those more
complex neural network based feature
extraction work is you operate in so a
graph space so you use of do a
convolution across the graph and so you
end up mixing features of nearby atoms
and that's something that yeah I've been
looking at an extending there's there's
already published papers on that it's
really interesting to look at it
wouldn't your fingerprints
okay.thank please encourage us